the solution is that we need to call
fragment that set has options menu true
that way we'll get appropriate options
menu callback methods in the fragment so
that we can inflate the menu and for
when a menu item is selected and this is
where the fragment inflates the menu
remember from before that in the
forecast fragment class we have a public
empty constructor and we also override
oncreateview we also define
fetchweathertask here now we're going to
override an additional fragment
lifecycle method called on create this
is where the fragment is created and
this happens before the oncreateview
method which is where the UI gets
initialized so in oncreate we're going
to call set has options menu to be true
to indicate that we want callbacks for
these methods when on create options
menu is called we're going to inflate
the menu layout that we defined earlier
called forecastfragment
we'll also get notified when a menu item
is selected when a menu item with ID
action refresh is called we're going to
return true for now we're going to go
over the activity and fragment lifecycle
methods in more detail in later lessons
but if you want you can read the
documentation linked below for now